met a very interesting  gentleman here what's your name  introduce yourself my name is brad nice  to meet you brad brad has an interesting  story we're going to have to go ahead  and have a monsoon to talk about he  approached me we just here doing uh at  this convention here conference and  talmud  you're actually a former pastor yes sir  i'm a former pastor i like to say that  the bible brought me to islam  if you take the gospels for as it says  and what the words of jesus say in red  letters and ignore paul it will bring  you to islam the apostle paul numerously  contradicts jesus christ and what he  says jesus commands us to follow one god  and commands us to be obedient to the  commandments and if you look at first  century christianity and what they  believed in their theology islam is the  only religion that practices first  century christianity  so that's why i learned so we've got a  lot to talk about yes  coming soon inshallah